en mettant le verbes au futur ou encore
juste un petit exemple par exemple que
je mangera
je résume interdit de renvoyer les ça
peut être par exemple des parents qui
n'ont jamais été à l'école donc qui ne
savent pas lire
ça peut être des questions de
fonctionnement de l'école
à quelle heure vous allez récupérer
comment ça se passe pour les papiers de
cantine lire les mots dans le cahier de
correspondance
[Musique]
maintenant c'est c'est un plaisir ou
vraiment et pour le moment rien n'est
beau d'aider ces enfants vraiment à
faire l'ère des fois pour aurait à
français
[Musique]
ne passez pas cette grippe c'est donc
savez pas ce qui s'est passé lors d'un
fois leur disais plus ou mois qui arrive
est ce que tu es plus ou moins vrai et
puis voilà certaines arpents de les
convoquer en fait finalement que
personne les mâles
[Musique]